all right U.S and Russian officials are
trading accusations after an American
drone collecting intelligence near
Ukraine's Coast crashed into the Black
Sea after a confrontation with Russian
fighter jets the Pentagon says a Russian
pilot knocked it out of its normal
flight path Russia denies that saying
the Drone was headed toward its airspace
David Martin has more
U.S drones frequently fly surveillance
missions over the Black Sea among other
things to monitor the fighting in
Ukraine Russian Fighters usually come
out to intercept them but this time they
seem bent on causing harm a Russian jet
approached from the rear dumping fuel
U.S officials believe the pilot meant to
come up in front of the Drone so it
would fly into the fuel Cloud but pulled
up too soon and clipped the drone's
propeller which is located in the back
John Sullivan was U.S ambassador to
Russia at the start of the war this is
just a sign of Russia's aggressiveness
and lawlessness in pursuit of the
special military operation it happened
75 miles Southwest of the Crimean
Peninsula a part of Ukraine seized by
Russia for more than half an hour two
Russian jets made a total of 19 passes
on the unarmed drone popping up in front
to blast it with their jet exhaust and
trying to drench it with their fuel on
the final pass the Russian pilot missed
his approach just bad piloting one
official said they collided with the
aircraft damaging the propeller and
essentially putting in a situation where
it was unfiable and uncontrollable this
was an aircraft that was flying an
international airspace intercepted by
much faster much more maneuverable
Russian fighter aircraft who were trying
to bring it down or force it down and
they're lucky they didn't lose one of
their own planes and pilots in doing so
now the Pentagon wants to recover the
wreckage before the Russians get to it
but is operating at a disadvantage since
there are no U.S Navy ships in the Black
Sea for CBS mornings David Martin the
Pentagon